I have to be honest I didn't expect
battlegrounds time to vent war mode to
get pulled this morning for server and
stability issues so this piece is gonna
have footage from two versions of the
game Pub G's team deathmatch experience
war mode is a lot of fun and proves the
game can grow outside of battle royale
but war mode also brings up some larger
issues about what happens to a game when
it strays too far from its core idea to
appeal the much larger audiences in many
ways it feels like battle royale became
popular because it wasn't just another
team deathmatch with pub G under a lot
of pressure from the exploding
popularity of fortnight with its smaller
faster matches timed events dance moves
in crazy costumes it feels like
something new has to happen for
battlegrounds while it's common for
games that need a dedicated player base
to try new modes later in their life
there's always the risk of watering down
the thing that makes the game so special
and turn off the people who got it to
where it is so is going to warm out a
good idea for pub G the answer is it's
probably a good first crack but drifts
too far let's dig in what's working in
war mode is that pub G's always had
strong shooting mechanics with
satisfying heft brutal and specific
sound design fun weapon attachments and
that signature moment-to-moment luck war
mode solidifies how good gunfights
really are and that this game can be
carried on shooting alone it's also a
nice palate cleanser from the long hikes
and quick deaths of Battle Royale what
isn't working as the payoff war mode
doesn't have the same intense emotional
investment players gather over long
periods of time and then gamble at the
last circle war mode cheapens the
chicken dinner
did that get your heart pounding
this feels largely due to lack of
objectives outside of racking up points
through knockdowns kills and revives
half the time you might not be doing
anything when around ends the challenge
for pub G is to find a mode that gives
the same level of excitement but with
less running and more shooting games
like Rainbow six siege have it nailed
unfairness surprisingly is also a
problem battle royale is fair because
it's always unfair but when you strain a
team deathmatch territory you suddenly
have to deal with the perception that
the game is stacked against you through
lack of skill based matchmaking
pre-selected loadouts and the one
mechanic that doesn't hold up
parachuting in war mode if you don't
plummet at full speed the parachute
often bugs out stalling above the ground
because players are dropping into a
region with a lot more fighting than
usual the extra hang time often gets you
K out in last night's version of war
mode players spawn in with random
weapons typically found in crates and
many were stuck with sniper rifles
players with assault rifles had a clear
advantage in the smaller fix zones where
fights took place it actually feels
worse to have an algorithm stack the
deck against you upfront then just drop
in with nothing and take your chances
so battlegrounds can either be totally
unfair all the time or transparent and
fair but there's danger in between
especially with cheating already
perceived to be an issue so shooting is
good parachuting is bad and the
emotional payoff isn't there yet
what would I suggest battlegrounds try
maybe we should dial it back to
something halfway in between TDM and
battle royale I'm pitching for rotating
king of the hill which is basically Corp
of G with respawns you drop in and fight
over a circle teams to get a point for
taking and holding it then the circle
would move and teams would have to rush
to a new spot this type of mode means
that the field constantly resets and
teams can find themselves attacking and
defending points you still get those
running or driving gunfights that make
battle royale what it is and pub G is
introduced to who can kill the most
enemies
I'd honestly like to see Babji succeed
and expand beyond its original idea
because the shooting just feels so good
in this game so what do you think how
does pub G compete with fortnight moving
forward what would you like to see next
or do you like the game as it is and
just want to see fewer bugs and better
rewards let's talk about your ideas in
the comments below and thanks for
watching
[Music]